because we're comedians so the best part
about our job is we usually don't have
to set an alarm and the seven day work
week does not apply to us shout out
labor day
yeah labor day so it's like this is a
day to celebrate all the [ __ ] work
it's like a big yeah cause labor day
what is it
what labor day the history is what we
celebrate the chinese building our
railroads that's
the underbite came out and there's no
way zhang jin would just sit in silence
okay so i'm just waiting for the muzzy
no but that was a positive thing for the
chinese they built they helped build the
[ __ ] railroads
yeah yeah that's a great country maybe
not [ __ ] [ __ ] on the chinese so
zach i think zach was right on that one
right
he wasn't really yeah there was no way
yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah it wasn't
necessarily offensive right zach
now let me ask you that jews no yeah it
was she gotta wait so it's actually
sunshine himself for that one yeah you
should wear yourself but he really means
that he really
yeah so so labor day so you want to talk
about this why do you want to talk about
this
because it is a friendly reminder david
think it's banged out your mom go ahead
it's just what happened
but you know what it is labor day and
you know
the new guy alex has [ __ ] white
sneakers on and that and i have white
sneakers on that's a faux pas
yeah but you know what that originated
that originated from all the rich
families coming back after their [ __ ]
last vacations
right of the summer and they decided
they were going to pack away all their
summer clothing
and get ready for the win then for work
and work means sitting around in their
house having people do work for them
yeah so labor day is a celebration that
celebrates the work of men and women
this is a day for [ __ ] linda stefano
who
[ __ ] sacrificed your whole life to
raise the magic the magic kid from
ridgewood
yeah [ __ ] it yeah and if alex thinks my
balls aren't going to go across the top
of that mustache while pretty woman's in
the background on my left side he's not
another thing
it's what it is it's what it is
so labor day's you know it's an
interesting thing because
basically you know the work the work
week used to be like seven days
really yeah yeah obviously is that when
we were [ __ ]
winning world wars that's when we were
like
becoming an industrialized nation and
these workers just had to work seven
days a week that's what the work the
work week used to just be seven days 12
hours a day seven days a week how
[ __ ] wild is that and then yeah
what's called
it's called slaves yeah pretty much it
wasn't slavery but it was pretty much
similar to that because are you
referring to slavery no you're talking
about like these are like
like slavery's out yeah the 1900s yeah
no wow
yeah i mean that's the you know that's
the kind of dark side of capitalism that
you have to admit
yes you need a balance with everything
in life and so the labor movement which
is what labor day really celebrates is
the labor movement which sort of
you know unions and protecting laborers
laborers and stuff like that
you need that you need that to balance
against the greedy capitalists
who if they could would make you work
seven days a week you know it's
just all the fake [ __ ] it's like
even when i was in england like all
england
all the british people were doing was
[ __ ] on america and like how
americans are the bad guys it's like
well then you go protect the oil
you you go use your military that you
[ __ ] barely have anymore and protect
the oil and let these [ __ ] shish
kabobs run around
yeah i like that what i said had nothing
to do with what you said and you just
used what i said as an opportunity
to get steel pipe a little bit yeah
because you didn't listen to a word i
said you just wanted to [ __ ] say
something patriotic i just want a
[ __ ] question i just want to call a
group of people shish kabob yeah and the
thing i didn't get away sean chen i was
just kidding i just
it's a character piece it's just a
character piece yeah i meant not to buy
it but it is funny to call
another human being a shish kebab yeah
and you could call me a shish kebab too
yeah you can't and i'm a shisha because
i'm a greek kid i'm
well and i'm a fish stick you are a fish
stick i'm a fish you're a [ __ ] fish
[ __ ] so it's alex a new guy his new
nickname's just going to be alex the new
guy the fish dick yeah alex the fish or
lapable
yeah yeah alex what do we like for him
lapable or fish
alex laps alex the fish stick or i'm
just going to call mister the
i stephanie that one yeah yeah and he's
from out on the island it seems mr
stepford now it's my [ __ ] husband
we're gonna get married oh he could
castle it's what it is it's what it's
gonna happen he's
a kid from [ __ ] long island but you
know the thing about
yeah the thing about the labor movement
because is that it was
actually believe it or not it was
because of jews
that we ended up getting a weekend the
jews were the ones that did it the jews
were the ones that didn't interest
they didn't want to work on the sabbath
so nice eventually thank you jesus
an employer gave in to them and gave
them saturday off and then saturday
inevitably became saturday and sunday
and what year was that johnny p
we're talking about the 1800s so in the
18th so before that it was just
the weekend wasn't a thing saturday was
just another day of the work
yeah i mean the the week is made up
seven day week is made up
right completely made up thing a seven
day week why isn't it a ten day why is
it in the three day was it a four day
well didn't caesar make that all up
isn't that something to do with uh
isn't that from like roman times with um
with like keeping time in order i mean
time is made up time is not a real thing
why is it 24 hours in a day well
here's the year marks one revolution of
the earth around the sun so that's based
on that
and months supposedly mark the time
between full moons
the seven day work week is based on
nothing
absolutely nothing interesting so the
seven day work was just some guy just
made
some [ __ ] guy made it up and i'm
trying to figure out who the [ __ ] guy
is but supposedly it has its roots
um that can be traced back to babylon
four
thousand years ago that's that's
interesting yeah the bible think about
that no and nobody ever really thinks
about the babylonians
they were just a bunch of they were a
[ __ ] civilization of babylonians
we're gonna do an episode in the
babylonians and there's a place in
there's a place called babel on long
island
there is a place called battle royale
yeah